alors alors c'est un exercice quotidien
pour samia elle appelle sa mère qui
habite port au prince pour s'assurer que
tout va bien commun la situation
aujourd'hui
depuis des semaines les manifestants
bloquent les routes du pays
les écoles sont fermées les épisodes de
violences se multiplient partout ya des
manifestations poterie à des baltes à
doha mais par exemple moi je sais je
veux pas je veux pas envoyer de l'argent
à ma part ce moment est seul dans une
maison si je n'en vois c'est elle qui va
sortir si je trouve quelqu'un a ici qui
peut le dépasser pour moi ok mais je
n'ai pas risquer que ma mère soit et ne
retourne plus à la maison ça c'est les
us les infirmiers de l'hôpital pierre le
gardeur
ce médecin qui se rend en haïti chaque
année avec des collègues est à ce point
préoccupé qu'il compte annuler leur
prochain voyage humanitaire ce qui s'y
passe est inquiétant pour la population
qui est déjà en haïti qui viennent
d'haïti
si on y va on y va pour un service pas
pour être bloqué dans un chemin dont qui
pourrait en sécurité c'est plus
raisonnable
de ne pas faire la mission cette année
c'est un rassemblement que nous avons
fait devant le bureau électoral de
monsieur justin trudeau
ces manifestants se sentait un peu
impuissants ils ont choisi de se
mobiliser
il demande à ottawa d'appuyer le peuple
haïtien nous demandons aussi qu'ils ne
soutiennent plus ce gouvernement du
journal mu et éventuellement invités à
quitter france andré compte maintenir la
pression tant qu'il le faudra
ils avaient tous les membres de la
communauté haïtienne à se joindre au
mouvement
j'ai l'impression que les gens sont
arrivés un point de désillusions aso
rock qui se disent bon cas ici c'est
fini pour nous ce qui se passe là bas ça
nous dépasse une crise endémique je dis
ça fait ça fait des décennies que ce
pays est en crise mais jusqu'à combien
de temps on va pouvoir tolérer et
supporter de crise après crise après
crise qui va là où le président je
venais le moïse refuse toujours de
démissionner comme le réclame la rue
difficile d'entrevoir une sortie de
crise certains autres à l'apport à ma
sécurité personnelle
je suis content d'être ici et que le
canada m'a accepté chez eux comme ça
puis ski accord mouvement c'est que je
me disais si j'étais dans mon pays
j'allais participer la contribution à
l'est côté pour aider mon pays à sortir
dans cette crise c'est bien souvent le
fardeau de ceux qui sont au canada en
sécurité mais loin des leurs le corps
ici
mais le coeur dans les antilles ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morrell